un viaje a los baños públicos de Tokio y
una historia de amor transgresora fueron
las protagonistas de la noche en cannes
la francesa
hizo un remarcado regreso a la
competencia de cannes la directora de 74
años presentó el verano pasado que
cuenta el romance entre una abogada de
renombre y su hijo político
la película transcurre en una casa
burguesa con jardines y carros de lujo
de una familia recompuesta Un día llega
ateo el hijo de 17 años que el padre de
familia tuvo con su primera esposa
teoconquista a Anne y poco a poco se
descubre el deseo de venganza de este
chico hace un padre ausente durante casi
toda su vida
[Música]
el cineasta Alemán benders con una
película de lo ínfimo perfect days
cuenta la rutina diaria de ira llama un
empleado de los servicios de limpieza de
los baños públicos de Tokio el respetado
actor japonés koji yakuso interpreta a
este trabajador modelo que realiza cada
día una labor minuciosa como si
desempleo dependiera su dignidad
[Música]
la legendaria higiene japonesa encontró
en esta película su mejor embajadora en
el cine una cinta poética sobre la
belleza de las cosas más simples
[Música]